All right. Awesome.
Yeah. So, evals, like I think eval feel
like this magic button. I think everyone
feels like, hey, my AI pipelines don't
work, but if I somehow solve evals, they
will start to work. Well, and I'll say
some people haven't even gotten there
yet. And like I think there's this like
especially when you're new to building
AI pipelines or you're new to a certain
technique or model which is pretty much
everyone all the time like no one is an
expert on every model and there's new
stuff shipping every every week every
month and I think it can be paralyzing
and it can kind of like kneecap the
productivity of your team when everybody
is trying different things in different
ways and without a way to understand hey
this approach works better than that
approach without a way to evaluate the
performance of whatever like problem
you're your new approach on on the
problem you're trying to solve. It's
it's kind of becomes impossible to make
progress and like by Bob said like it
becomes this magic bullet where it's
like okay if we just had a number from 0
to 100 that said here's how good we are
in this approach versus this approach
versus this approach. Hey we changed
this thing and we got better here but we
got worse here. um it kind of can be
very grounding and helps you bring a lot
more than engineering back into your
process. Does that sound right? I think
so. But I think um I think that's the
feeling at least and the thing that I
have mostly captured. So I think the
first time I really started thinking
about machine learning eval uh came from
when I was working on hollow ones. Um,
and that was the first time where I had
a completely stochastic system, uh,
where you really can't there's no ground
truth because capturing ground. So, for
context, for everyone else that doesn't
know, hollens is an AR headset and part
of the AR headset job is to build a 3D
representation of the world that it sees
through the cameras it
has. And in order to do that perfectly,
the only way you can build eval is to
build a simulation that perfectly
simulates the camera hardware, which you
cannot do. like you cannot actually
mimic how light is captured by the
camera sensors perfectly. So the next
best thing we can do is capture
something that is pretty close to
correct and for that you're going to use
another sensor and that sensor itself
will have some errors. So we built this
pipeline out that had some ground truth
and we tried to use that ground truth
and tried to align it but then we ran
into problems like windows and mirrors
which basically don't get captured by
any sensor very well. Um, and then we
had to like those existed in our data
set. Like I'm in this conference room
right now. I'm surrounded by windows.
That's a real data set and we want we
wanted the hall lens to work in there.
So we had to approximate what it meant
to have some sort of a score. And like
let's say the the hall lens misses one
square meter of an area and capturing a
wall. Is that good? Is that bad? Like
how do you evaluate is one square meter
versus 1.2 two square meters any worse
or better and that's so it almost
becomes like a question of like where do
we spend our time and like what matters
to the actual kind of and output of how
how good is our system as seen from like
what outcome is it trying to drive
exactly so that's one part of it and the
other part is can you even measure
correctness like how do you know if the
one square meter you missed was actually
a real hole or a hole that the other
sensor also missed like is it a hallucin
Funny enough, we used to call them
hallucinations as well. Um, they're like
hallucinated fragments and like how bad
are hallucinated 3D assets that the
Hollands picked up that didn't exist in
the real world? And measuring that was
incredibly hard. We actually had a
full-time person. We actually had like
one and a half full-time people whose
full-time job it was for over two years
to at best approximate some sort of
metric. And we had no real metric in the
end. It was it was just a pseudo
approximation of the real system. And we
did this for all sorts of things. We did
this for handtracking when we built
handtracking. We did this for
eyetracking when we did
eyetracking. And that's when I first
realized like there is no EVOS truth.
There is no golden data set ever for
most real
problems. Um that's funny. Uh Adisha. Um
uh and then it really comes to a matter
of how do you balance engineering time
that you have to do to build a system
that can at best
approximate the actual thing the proxy
for what you're trying to build for.
Does that align with what uh what you've
seen too as Dex in the now the LLM
world?
Yeah. And I I I see it as kind of like a
gradual process too. Like I know I know
we're going to start like we're going to
get into this but like every project
starts with nothing. Like if there was
already an eval a really good eval for
the problem you're solving then it's
almost certain that someone else is
already kind of on well on the way to
solving that problem. And the hard
problems to be solved in AI tend to be
the ones where no eval set exists or no
eval set exists that is appropriate for
the way that you're approaching it or
the way you want to evaluate your
solution. And so I think the tricky part
is like a lot of teams get sucked into
cool, we're gonna spend six months
building our eval set and then we're
just gonna push it out and go. And I
think what's a lot more interesting is
this kind of more agile incremental
engineering approach of how do we start
with nothing? How do
we make it pretty good to start and how
do we keep updating it and evolving the
way we evaluate our software over time?
Yeah, exactly. And Dex and I put
together some topics that we want to
talk about today. Uh Dex, do you want to
copy and paste them into the chat really
fast?
Um I will do you one better. I will push
up um the readme which has the topics in
it. Even better. Okay. Uh and while
you're at it, do you want to and I'll
link that. You just want to screen share
really fast then in that case. Uh sure.
Cool.
So when we first think about evals, I
think it's more of a journey rather than
an answer right now. And any company
that starts off saying that we're going
to build evals automatically. It's just
going to solve everything is going to be
stuck because you could spend you could
spend your entire company's lifetime
building
evals.
Um, so what I want to I think what we
want to talk about is how do we go from
no evals to some evals to really good
evals in an incremental way for any
problem that you have today rather than
just like what exactly is a great eval.
And by the way, we're recording all of
these so we'll post it on YouTube soon
and you'll have access to all of
them. So uh yes, sorry, give me give me
just one second here.
Yeah. Um, and today's conversation is
going to be really, really interactive.
So, if people have problems that they
specifically want to pose that we should
talk about, definitely feel free to just
like chime in and ask, uh, you can post
it in the chat and we're happy to
discuss those as well. Um, the number
one sneak peek that I'll give everyone
before uh, we get too into it is please
stop using numbers to evaluate your
systems. Do not ask an LLM on a scale of
1 to 10, how good is the answer. stop
asking it confidence scores. Um
because and and I'll give you intuition
how to how to think about this problem
and why that matters. How many of you
actually like ask confidence scores just
like humans? Mike. Um how how many of
you use confidence scores today? Can you
like type in the chat or uh really
quickly?
Okay. Come on all of you please shame
yourselves. I allow you to shame
yourselves. It's okay. It's we're an
open place right now. You should have
you should have asked them first and
then told them that it was bad. No, no,
I think it's, you know, it's part of it.
You gota you got to acknowledge what
five steps of grief. You just got to
acknowledge it first. And once we've
accepted it, um then we can talk about
it. Um Okay, cool. Um Okay, cool. Uh I'm
just going to merge this in right now.
There's some Okay, work in progress
code. Uh some of this may change
throughout the episode folks, but uh
let's pull up the evals workshop. Okay,
cool. So yeah, here's what we want to
talk about today.
So much the main topics are really going
to go about why eval are really good and
what you can do if you have an answer
key. And I think that's hopefully should
be pretty obvious.
Okay, Dex, sorry. I'm gonna make you
call. Sorry. Yeah, I'll get unmuting
folks, too. Okay, there you go. you're
um you're made a co-host and like why we
can what we can do if we actually have
an answer key. Um and that should be
really obvious, but the most important
thing remember we talk about this all
the time on these episodes. The number
one thing you need to build a really
good AI pipeline is a really fast
iteration loop. Evals are your way to
iterate fast. Uh not initially but
eventually. If you have a team of 40
people contributing to your codebase,
you need evals just like you need unit
test because that's what prevents CI/CD
from breaking. And you need to do that
not because developers are bad, but
because we're all lazy and we all do
push code sometimes and CI/CD does a
really good job of checking for
mistakes,
right? So that's that workflow of like
make a change, run the eval, see if it's
better or worse, and then like don't
push code that makes the eval worse.
Yeah. And like how do you measure if
it's worse or not is a totally separate
question. But in proxy that's really
what we want to go do. And you want an
easy way to go do that. Visualizing
results. We'll talk about that in a
second as well. I'm going to flag that's
a good question. Can you add that in
your local notes tab? Yeah. Yep. Yeah, I
was about to do that. I love that. Okay.
Um Oh, you're screen sharing. Okay. Let
me screen share my tab because then we
can
um the next question I want to talk
about is how do you actually build an
answer key? because at least for me most
things I work on have no answer key on
the on the very beginning and those are
also the most interesting things that we
could have. Um so we'll talk about how
to build an answer key from
nothing. Hint the answer is you know how
there's vibe
coding. You should be vibe evaling in
the beginning and vibe coding
but you should be vibe evaling in the
beginning if you haven't used a lot of
LLM. you should 100% be vibe evaling and
we'll talk about why in a second as
well.
The the other
thing the other thing that I think is
really worth noting is a lot of people
look at emails as
holistic but structured data versus
unstructured data is a huge difference
in the way that we do emails and I think
like Dex and I have talked about this a
lot. Uh so like Dex, do you want to
share some thoughts? Yeah. So I mean
like you have all these different So I I
feel like where we got off the track a
little bit like as an industry with eval
was doing all this work to understand
unstructured data and how good it was
because then you get all these things
like sentiment categories and is the
model outputting text that's rude like
you have all these like kind of like
baked in eval becoming a little bit like
industry standard as far as like okay
the first thing you can do is just pull
this thing off and make sure your model
is not recommending that people go you
know do something dangerous I won't go
into details but um um things like that
and so that's like and so it's like okay
we need evals in the sense of like we
need one LLM to read all this
unstructured data and
then decide whether it's yes or no on a
bunch of these like binary classifiers
or like multiple category classifiers
um versus like a problem that I work
with a lot is like extracting structured
data from images and being able to say
like hey here's uh a hundred pictures of
a
passport like can we reliably pull the
data out of that passport and for that
our answer key is very structured it's
literally a list of JSON fields versus
like you know can we get a one to 100
score either you know hey we have a
100red outputs from the model, which of
how what percentage of them like pass
all our, you know, style guidelines as
far as how we want our chatbot to behave
or something? Does that little rambly,
but does that make sense? That nailed
it. That's um and then really it's like
this and then there's a blend of the two
as well where I have some structured
data and I can eval that with like
programmatically and some of it has to
be eval because I'm getting a summary.
But even summaries, people are like,
"Oh, I can only know if it's a good
summary or not if I use an LLM." But
that's not actually true. Let's look at
the idea of like summarizing something.
I can know how many sentences things
have. I can know how many what the word
count of the summary is. I can and I I
can know how many how long it is. Um,
and then I can even know something like
does it mention specific key words that
it really should mention the summary.
Like if I ask for a summary about like
um uh if I ask for let's say a summary
about like like a Wikipedia
article, it should probably mention some
of the key figures in the Wikipedia
article up front and I should probably
know what those key figures are ahead of
time and some of them. Yeah, I feel like
we need to we need to hit the
whiteboard. People are Pashant is asking
what's an answer key. Um yes, I think
let's let's define some of this stuff.
Um I will drop you the link real quick.
Thank you. Um or do you want to do you
want to share and uh just tell me the
link in my DMs?
Yeah. Um so and and I think sorry for to
catch everyone else. An answer key is
something like a rubric. Like in the
case of like a classification problem,
an answer key could be something as like
uh here's the correct classes for all
these categories. In the case of like a
resume problem, the answer key could be
something more like um here's the fields
that I wanted to extract. In the case of
a chatbot, it could be the sentiment
that a user should be feeling at any
given point in the chatbot
itself. It really depends on the kind of
problem you have, but the idea is that
your answer key is as close to an
approximation about the correctness
uh that you
have. And like it could be sentiment and
yeah, so I'll copy and paste a couple
more thing. It could be sentiment. It
could be like intent
capturing. So like we capture the intent
that the user asks us about correctly
and exact. Okay. So that's something
like someone comes in and says I want to
buy a new phone and we want to validate
that that becomes you know browse
products.
Exactly. Right. And it might even
include browse products subcategory
field a subcategory phone as another
thing,
right?
Like we might want all of that. And that
might be like we might want and the
accuracy of our system that we want
might be, hey, you know what? For our
system, we're we're pretty happy if it
got to the browse products phone. were
very happy if it got to the product's
phone page, but it's like, oh, it's it's
our choice about how strict we want to
go make
this. And I think the key part about
having an answer key here is like if if
we go deep deeper into like this I want
to buy a phone thing that Dex wrote out
is like at this point many of us know
that we're going to have like a
multi-step pipeline. We're going to have
like some sort of intent detection. Um
after we have intent detection
uh yeah after we have intent detection
we might route to like a different part
uh different things based on what the
user is trying to do and we can build
evals for different parts of the system.
So even though this whole thing is the
chatbot, we could build eval just to say
that did we pick the right arrow down
here? Is the intent selection good
without even really arguing about like
whether the subbox in here operated
correctly. It doesn't have to be binary.
That's the whole point that I was
making. It's your choice. Obviously, if
it's binary, it's going to be more easy
to
evaluate. But if it's not binary and
some problems just cannot be binary like
in the case of summarizing an uh
summarizing a Wikipedia article, it's
virtually impossible to make that a
binary
classification. But what it can be is a
great approximation for what we think is
the
truth. And I think that sounds a little
vague. So I want to I want to talk about
how to go do that really quickly.
So okay, see what I'm doing here? Yeah,
does this make sense? Like this is like
how you would basically write this in
Python. Um and obviously you don't want
to handw write a unit test for all
these. This looks a lot like um like a
table table test basically where you
basically for a big set of inputs and
outputs you would just make assertions
about them. And like you could do this
in JSON or you could do it in CSV, but
like you have your input and then you
have your expected output. Exactly.
And like this is not fun. This is not
fun to go right. Yeah. And you can do
this anywhere. Like uh the reason that
like Dexter is probably saying that he
he's writing this in Python directly is
because the more sophisticated your
agent get like as of today like BAML
doesn't allow you to compose functions.
So you just can't write certain types of
expectations really well. Yeah. But one
of the most important things is this
word that Dexter says which is a table
test. And Dexter said this because he's
worked in these kinds of systems for a
while now. But I want to articulate to
everyone what that
means. So when I'm doing a table test,
and this is something to think about as
you build more complicated emails. A
table test for concept is to say that
hey output has multiple fields in it. It
has an input, it has an intent and a
subclass. Just because it doesn't match
this perfectly doesn't mean it failed. I
really want a table that says out did
output.intent match what I want and did
output.ass match what I want. It's a
table test and I can run both of them in
parallel without running only one. And
that is incredibly useful when building
LLM outputs. And I want to show a real
um I'm
just I'm pseudo coding over here. Ad
just talking about summarizer. So I want
to share like a couple different
examples of ideas here. So this is how
we could build an intent classifier test
case. And you could actually imagine
even further, what if this was a
chatbot, but I had like a probe, and we
talked about probes a few times that I
passed into my
system that was able to introspect
specific nodes in here, and then I could
be like
probe. And actually analyze the intent
into my chatbot and actually know
exactly what happened. Oh, I see. So
you're instrumenting through the steps,
but you're actually running you're
actually running you can and you could
also make assertions about the output
but it's actually like you know that if
the what comes what gets bubbled out of
the probe is correct then then that's
cor then then then the output you don't
care like of the non-deterministic if
the output itself is like plain text
then it's really hard to evaluate if
that's it's harder to evaluate if that's
correct or not but you can guarantee
that the internals of the method
actually were executed properly. Exactly
right. So like right over here we talked
about like this chatbot concept where
the output is going to be a message
that's shown to an end user but we know
our chatbot consists of many different
substeps. So right over here one of the
substeps could be intent analysis. So we
called we actually output out of our
system the probe that tells us what the
intent is and any other subcategories or
steps that we find very
useful and then we would actually return
that to
us. Does does that kind of make sense
Dexter? It does. Are you are you
drawing? I'm not seeing your stuff
updating. Okay. Yeah. Um about a couple
more. But people seem to be really
curious about how do you do things for
summarizers and then also how do we do
things for a couple other scenarios. So
while we do this um I'm going to send
over a YouTube video uh to show and I
think this is probably the best example
that I can have. Can I screenshot
Dexter? Yeah. Um okay.
Yeah, you can steal it. Go for it.
Okay. Uh one second. I'm going to do one
more thing.
Okay. So, now let's talk about a couple
more things that I want to talk. People
talked about summarization. So, I'm
going to get to that in a second, but I
want to talk about like other kinds of
things. So, uh we've worked with a
couple finance companies for quite some
time now. And I think a lot of people
don't realize how to think about
eval. So, I'm not going to mute the
video and I'll just talk through it. Uh,
if my internet would catch up, I'm at
140p. Um, I'm at 1080p. So, what the
Here we go. What the goal of this video
is is we're going to extract data out of
financial records, all kinds of
financial records. Um, and normally I'll
run this code live, but it's just easier
because I don't want to share I don't
have the actual PDFs on me right now.
So, it's just easier to go run this. And
we all know how to go build this sort of
thing. This basically becomes like a
data model that has a a class with all
these fields attached to it. And then we
also add a category near each one to
know what category it is. So in this
case we have cash, mutual fund, um, and
ETFs as a category. And we can see that
the data pulls out. We all know LM can
go do this. It's an extraction problem
out of images. It's not too hard. We can
go write this out. But now we get into
the more interesting part, which is how
could we build an eval system for this?
Well, one way is one of us could
actually handw write the golden JSON for
this automatically.
Um, and if you do haven't done anything
like this before, you should handw write
the golden data set for your JSON
automatically. And the reason that you
should do that is not because there's no
easier way, but because the first time
you handw write a golden data set, you
are actually going to find
inconsistencies in your data model that
make it look wrong. It's going to make
you think about the problem in a way
that very few things ever will. And
that's that's kind of key to all of this
eval stuff is like define if you don't
know what your inputs look like and what
your the structure of your outputs look
like it becomes really hard to build
your test data set. Exactly. Jonathan
said it need to build the intuition and
that's kind of the whole point about
like when we were actually going to when
when we built BAML the whole point of
hitting play in the playground was to
help you build that intuition. That's
why I say five evals are the best
because if you have no eval, the best
thing you can do is look at the output.
That is literally the best thing you can
go do. As the model outputs something
reasonable, you know, you're probably on
the right track. But as you grow, you
can't vibe eval because we're all busy
people and we don't want to vibe
forever. So want to build something
better. So we're going to build
systematic ways to go do this. So So for
this, you can imagine building a golden
data set of all of these exact financial
transactions. And in my golden data set,
I may be okay if asset name doesn't
match perfectly. I'm okay with that. I
want the symbol to be perfect. I want
quantity to be perfect. I want current
price to be perfect. And I want cost
bases and market value to be perfect. So
you can see how I can even have a blend
of correctness on my golden data set
where I want I want a warning if the
asset name doesn't uh fire and I want to
visualize that in some way but I want
everything else to be completely
correct and I think we could all go
write that JSON but now we can do
something
else which is in this specific data
model we actually have some validations
that are built into place and we can do
runtime evals that means eval on
production data naturally over time. So
what would one of those look like? Does
anyone have an idea? Actually, I'm going
to pose this before I spoil it. Does
anyone have an idea of given this data
model, what do they see as a possible
runtime
eval? You can unmute to talk or you can
just like type in chat.
I assume we're not including like the
type of the dollar value should be a
number and not a string, right? Like
let's go beyond that. We get that. So
Matt has a really good idea. Column sums
data from an API is another great one.
Um you could make sure that the cost
basis times the price equals the market
value or I don't know there's some
there's some like row-wise computation
there that's supposed to that that's
supposed to add up, right? I don't do I
don't do finance. Exactly. And like this
is exactly what the mouse is going to
show. It's like quantity current price
should equal market value. We know that
that is a mathematical truth in our data
model. And guess what? We can actually
go build that
out. Like we can actually just go do
that. That's a really really fast
operation that we can go do. It's pure
programmatic. And we can just look at
the delta.
Uh right. And BAML supports this, right?
Are we going to go into that or are we
gonna That's like that's like runtime
evals, right? That's that's kind of
that's a separate thing how you do it
like we can talk about in a second. Like
yes, you can do this in BMAL, but that's
not the point here. I think the point
here is look at your data model and
think about what you can go do with your
data models to see if you have some
constraints you can build in. And this
isn't just a one-way thing you can build
in. You can actually build
in multiple sums given this data model.
I could say that hey, all my cash value
should equal this cash
value. All my mutual fund value should
equal this mutual fund value. I can even
have summings built in, not just
multiplications per row, but AC a sum
across columns as well, which can help
me build even more assurance that the
data is correct. And I'll give you an
example about what happens when this
data goes wrong. So, we have another
document here. I hope you can see and
I'm going to fast forward to the point
where it's like done processing. And and
while you're doing that just like very
clearly this is this is interesting
because it it it draws a line between I
mean we looked a little bit at some of
the testing stuff but basically these
are all deterministic evals. This is not
a model outputting whether something is
yes or no. This is you do the math in
runtime code and decide whether the
extraction is correct or not. Exactly.
So here you can see exactly what the
model did. The model took out this stock
form and pulled out a bunch bunch of
data about it. And check out what it did
here. It said that the price of Nvidia
Corp was
113.063. And look at this price right
over here.
Oh no. Right. And you can see why the
model did this. It didn't do it for any
other number, but it did do it for
Nvidia. Um, and it looks like what ended
up happening is the model did this and
later realized that that was dumb and
chose not to do it ever again, but it
didn't. Um, and normally this could be a
huge issue if the model did something
like this. Imagine you're transacting
across millions of entries uh and
millions of stocks. You could easily
have this could be a major like major
issue on an accounting balance sheet.
But we can do the same math again. We
turn that on. You can see how fast it is
because we're not actually using an LLM.
We're purely modeling it
out. And now we actually are running
this out and now we found that it's off
by 27 cents. And that makes sense
because 0.003 * 90 is 27 cents. We found
the discrepancy. And the idea here is
often a technique that we use in machine
learning is that one thing might be
wrong. But it's statistically very
unlikely that you get the right you get
the wrong quantity, the wrong current
price, and the market value adds up
correctly. It's very unlikely for that
to
happen. So we we're using law of
probabilities. And then even more
unlikely is that all the market values
added up together will equal to the
total market value up here.
So we're just building probabilistic
systems and obviously mistakes can still
happen, things can still go wrong, but
it's it's we're just building a system
of
unlikely. Uh and that's all we can do.
Just like with humans, it's a
probabilistic system and if we multiply
enough probabilities together, they get
really really
small. So now that we have this mistake,
what can we do about it? Well, the
beautiful thing about building a system
like this is we have a couple of
options.
One, what we can do is we can say we can
just have a human come in and go update
this. Two, we can just record that it's
an error. Three, we can go run this over
and over again until we get the right
answer. Or four, what we could do is we
could have another LM say, "Hey, Nvidia
Corp was off by 27 cents. Give it just
the data for Nvidia Corp and ask it to
extract only Nvidia
Corp." And now the LM is much more
likely to get it correct. because you're
giving it information about the
inconsistency. You don't even have to
say what is inconsistent. You can just
say when I do quantity times current
price uh equals market value, I get a
delta of 27 cents. And now the model can
all autocorrect. So now you've go you
can go solve this
problem.
So I'm going to I'm going to pause here
about numbers. It sounds like people get
the point about numbers and pashant is
asking uh I think the best question
which is how do we do this for string
evals and I think does anyone have an
idea of what I'm going to go
say reax close um I think it's more
about two aspects of it one is In the
very beginning, you should build a
diffing system that allows you to see
the diff between the previous run and
the and the most recent run. Oh yeah,
we've done this when we were like
migrating APIs for super systematic
stuff of like, hey, we're going to move
a 100 endpoints to a new system. Like,
show me the diff between all the old
endpoints and all the new endpoints.
Exactly. And a lot of people ask like,
damn, does that mean I have to build
custom UIs to go do all the stuff or
like can I just use something off the
shelf? And I've gone through this battle
a lot uh in a lot of different orgs and
we've made totally different decisions.
Uh we made different decisions on Face
ID, we made different decisions in
Hollands, we made different decisions at
D Shaw and with all the people that we
worked with, I've seen people make
different choices.
The answer that I have seen
um the uh the answer that I have seen
all the time is actually
that bespoke UIs end up powering your
team a lot more than you think and
because of things like v0ero it's not
that hard to build. I was going to say
in the last year the calculus has
shifted a lot between should we build
something in house to like kind of just
visualize some data real quick versus
like do we need to go get a tool or an
open source project and deploy it off
the shelf like if I were every time I
build evos for any data set this is my
workflow whether no matter what it is I
have a JSON object that I'm rendering I
know the type of that JSON object all
the time um and then every single time
actually for every single use case I
actually build a unique bespoke renderer
for that JSON object. I'm like like diff
these two things for me. And like
sometimes I want I want the diff to be
exact, sometimes I want to be
approximate, I just like vzero my way
through it. It takes about an hour, but
if the system I'm working on is really
sensitive and I'm looking to like 100
plus input output pairs, it is worth
building. If I'm looking at like 10, I
just look at it manually and just look
at and just like compare the files
myself. So the number one go ahead.
Sorry. No, I mean that kind of
attraction was something I think um I've
heard I forget who was saying it but
basically like someone who talked to a
ton of founders doing evals for
production enterprise stuff was
basically like almost nobody is stressed
out about building the test harness for
eval whether it's the thing that runs
the test whether it's the thing that
evaluates the results what whether it's
the thing that visualizes the results
everybody agrees that the hardest thing
is getting the golden data set and
getting the actual answer key correct
Yeah. Uh, one thing I wish were better
for support was for things beyond React.
Yeah, I really wish there was. Um, I
mean, we we've been looking into how to
build different UIs automatically for
different data models for you, but it
turns out to be a very challenging
problem. We're just going to wait and
sit and look a little bit longer before
we like I see something some patterns
more so emerge. But I do think there's
another question here. Um, why why is
the LM doing math in the neural network?
Shouldn't it be using a math tool call?
Oh, this isn't actually doing math for
for by the way, what this data set is
doing is like it's just saying like,
hey, I have this data model and this
data model, if I can pull the whole
sheet up somewhere, this actually has
market value, price, quantity, and
everything in here. And I'm just like
pulling out all the data from like a
data I have. So, this blue column is
basically not computed by an LM. This
blue column is added after the
extraction happens by deterministic
code. Exactly. It's literally just a
React thing that I said where the value
of this column is equal to the
multiplication of these two things. So,
I'm not actually doing this in in the
LM. If if you're doing this in the LM,
you're wrong. Don't do that. Uh don't m
just like multiply the numbers. You
don't need an LM to wait for the math to
do the
math.
Um so, I want to talk about u what yeah,
I want to talk about something more
specific. So, I'm going to pull up an
example that I think is going to help
make everything more concrete.
Um, so for example, my my mother is a
teacher. Um, and part of what she does
is she makes lesson plans and you could
imagine that we can go to an LLM and ask
it to make a lesson plan for us. And
that could be good. So, let's go take a
look at how I'm just going to write a
basic prompt that makes a lesson plan.
And I hope the lesson plan example is
good enough because it's very textually
heavy. And we can talk about how one
could make that better. Does that sound
good to everyone in terms of like a
problem that sounds uh relevant?
So the so the inputs and the outputs to
that system would be like a couple
sentences about the lesson plan and then
the output would be kind of a you know
two-page structured document of like hey
here's how to structure it and here's
all the steps and here's the worksheets
and stuff like that. I don't know. Let's
just see what it does given a All right.
Yeah. Let's see what we get. Something
something like that though, right? Like
the the interface is okay. So it's going
to do something. Yeah. You put in a
topic and then it generates the lesson
plan. Yeah, it'll do something. And like
I think the first question we all have
is how the heck do we measure that?
Um, and like this is probably good
enough. Um, so I'm just going to copy
this and I'm going to open cursor and am
I sharing cursor?
There's a there's a BAML source in the
directory for this episode if you want
to use that.
Am I sure?
Uh oh, we're still seeing your browser.
Which I will share my whole screen, I
guess. Okay. Yeah.
And then let's go to designing evals and
then I'm going to put this and put like
lesson plan in
here. So now we have a lesson plan. Um
and I think the first thing to think
about how to do emails is remember
ignore the fact that it's generated by
an LLM. It doesn't matter. The only
thing I really have to eval here is
given some topic, I will produce this
lesson plan data model. The fact that an
a single LM call produces it, the fact
that a whole composition of workflows
produces it, the fact that I sent it
over to some like mechanical Turk that
filled it out for me doesn't
matter. All that matters is given some
string, I'll produce this data model. So
now I know what I'm building. when I
write an email, I don't I actually kind
of ignore the fact that this lesson plan
works. So like what and this is that
idea of like semi-structured data where
you're outputting JSON but the fields in
the JSON are strings which are hard to
evaluate deterministically. Yeah, like
right over here, right? Like like I
don't even know what it did but it's
like it's outputting something and like
I don't know maybe this is good. So one
of the things that I can do is like time
allocation. Instead of this being a
string, let's just make this like um
int and like alias this to uh time
allocation
mins. So the first thing I can do is I
can put um I can change one of my fields
to be a
number. So now I have a number this like
45 minutes. Now what I might want to do
when I actually do my lesson plan is and
I think this is the part where people
get
stuck. Evaluate lesson
plan. Oops. uh client. Okay,
cool. Instead of viewing this as an
instead of viewing this as a method, all
I really need to do here is I need to
say given a topic string lesson plan,
I'm going to produce some evaluation
result for it.
What's the result? Is that going to be a
structured object or is that going to be
a string or what? That's the whole
point. I could do a string as an
evaluation for my lesson plan and then
what I could do as a human is I could go
analyze it myself. you go read the
string. I could literally I could read
the string. I could literally be like uh
be like evaluate the lesson plan for
third uh for third grade students blah
blah blah and it'll just output
something and I could and this is
basically like a standard this is like
LLM is judge, right? Like you could this
doesn't even have to be an you could
this could be a dynamic thing you do at
runtime inside your pipelines if you
wanted to, right? and you just save it
somewhere and every single time a user
reports it as bad, you flag that
database entry for the lesson plan with
its evaluation that you don't show the
user Yeah. to someone on your team and
they look at it and you go and now
you've kind of built an answer set of
like of some sort of evaluation set on
there like this topic or this lesson
plan was good, this topic or this lesson
plan was bad and now you've built some
sort of proxy for it and you might even
find like the string to be helpful in
deciding
that. Now there's another thing we can
do. We can actually uh yeah so rating
systems are bad. Please do not use
numbers. Anyone that use numbers is
wrong. So we can actually write an
evaluation from this. Now what makes a
good lesson plan? Like we can say
pacing the how good is the pacing and
the pacing can be can be slow, medium,
fast. And maybe I care about how fast
the system is. And I I just want to know
is the topic too fa fast. Maybe I want
to know like what kind of biasy bias
towards uh
biases uh string array any biases in the
lesson plan that I might want to know.
Like maybe there are topics that we
shouldn't be covering or examples that
we shouldn't be covering and I want to
flag them. They could be examples of any
kind. Uh and I can even like add
something else here. anybody that could
be problematic that could uh make a
student feel uncomfortable and I could
assert that in the lesson plan
evaluation this thing is empty like I
always want biases to be empty and very
very validate that I could talk about
like yeah the the one that really stood
out to me was like a lot of these need
like six different materials like
construction paper and glue and scissors
and stuff like that and like you could
evaluate like price of materials or
something like or like scope of mater
and then so sorry as we build this if we
if we run these things is the idea to
kind of build our eval system and then
tweak our core prompt and then like see
how our score changes exactly and it
actually becomes really easy to even
write this now we have like deaf lesson
plan test
harness and like it can be a topic which
is a stir
Right. Sorry, I can't type very
fast. From client import. Basically,
what we're taking away from this is like
there's there's nothing too fancy going
on here. This is all just prompting the
LM in structured ways to get it to talk
about what's going on. Exactly. And now
I can build I can build
assert. I can build like the
pacing is not equal to
fast right. I can assert that biases
do
len is zero. I can say the cost is less
than like $5. Maybe I'm okay with
student spending $5 on a lesson plan or
something. Um and then I can even say
like like I can even require like I can
say like is
quality equals
input is that
good? I can even like print um print uh
and at the very end I can even have a
last part of my eval just have a human
go look at it. So you can see how I can
build up my systems automatically and
like decide where my criteria is. Like
hey I work in a slightly poor school
district so I want to make sure that
costs are never going to be a problem.
In fact I want all my lessons plans to
be free and I want to build a system
that optimizes for free. And it might
even be like one of the things in the
topics are like
constraints which are a string that I
pass in that should be passed in to my
lesson
plan. And this could be a boolean or
something else. This could even be a
data model of some kind that produces
some string on its own which is like I I
what type of school district are you
working
for? Is there we can evog
uh if this is something being run live
can we evoglo? Yes. So the e-log and
live data is something I always talk
about. So like this is an example that I
use pretty often that many of you would
probably have seen by now. Oops.
Sorry, what is
wrong? Um, sorry. I'm gonna run my Give
me one second. I'm gonna move this so
you don't see my API
key. Okay, there we
go. Give me one second. So, like in this
case, imagine I'm processing millions of
Cambodia visas. And obviously, we can do
things in eval here. One of the things I
can do in Eval is literally build the
exact JSON that they should pull out.
And I'm very sensitive to certain things
like I want to make sure that it
correctly checks these check boxes off.
Maybe I don't care if it I want to make
sure it gets a personal information
perfectly correct. I may not care
perfectly about the address or
everything else because I can use
corroborating information to find that
information. Yeah. Sorry, real quick.
And maybe to guide this a little bit, uh
I'm really curious to know like let's
say you've processed a hundred of these
visa forms and you've pulled out the
schema and you have your golden data
set. Like how can you make a statement
about like I am now confident that we
are 98% accurate in extracting data from
forms like this like how can you how can
you kind of take the past results and be
able to say you know reliably like we
expect our future performance to be 98%
or 91% or whatever it is. Yeah, that's
usually where people struggle and and
the answer is you can't actually make
that statement perfectly. You're missing
a step in order to make that statement.
You make the golden data set once and
now you're like our pipeline works on a
golden data set at this percentage of
accuracy and meets our criteria to ship,
right? How do you know if you've over
bid to that data set though, right? So
what you do then is you actually have to
spot check your production data at some
cadence and continue adding to your
golden data set at some cadence. That I
I know you're I interrupted you in the
middle of talking about this thing, but
it could be useful um after to pull in
and like what does the architecture of
that pipeline look like? like where what
where in the where in where in the
process are you storing stuff and like
how do how do you how do you build that?
So I mean this is just one way to do it
but you don't actually have to just to
be very clear. Um what you really need
to capture when you go down this road is
did I did I capture everything? Oh yeah,
let me change
this. What you really want to do when
you go down this road? How do I change
this 30? You're you're talking about
just like capture every every input
output pair. Literally have to capture
every input output pair and there's no
shortcut around this at all. And more
specifically, what you really want to go
do is give it a second is when this data
comes back in or out, what you really
want to say is like how well is my is
blog post function doing and you just
have to spot check and look at is blog
post. And there's no good shortcut for
this. You have to build up your eval set
continuously over time and you have to
say like for this HTML page, is this
actually the right title on the blog
post? And like you can imagine a title
for a blog post is like I don't freaking
know like maybe um is this the right
title? Is this a blog post? Is this not
a blog post? And for context just to
show everyone what this was running on
is I made a small little demo that I
wanted to go do which was when I go
extract data from like a let's say I
have a bunch of blogs. I want to go see
for every single blog on a entire site
what is it a what's the value ratio? Is
it balance? Is is it an ad or is it
educational content? How deep of
educational content is it? Then like
what insights does it have? So it's
probably very easy for me to like
actually build a golden data set around
primary
intent. That is really easy. Key
insights is going to be much harder for
me to go do. But what I can say is
Nex.js should be mentioned in key
insights
somewhere. So I can just reax for that
for this specific blog post, not for
everything, but for this one. And
that'll take me time. The other thing I
can do is I can rerun this same exact
data model on my next prompt and just
see what it output out next
time and just look at the diff between
these two
structures. Yes, exactly. Yes. For now,
like and it's not it's not even living
in your code. I think that's the most
important part.
It's not even living in your code. It's
living in a hybrid of your code and your
data. And that is the part that most
people miss. Evals are not purely living
in your code because eval are purely a
diffing
mechanism. You have to be able to sorry,
what does living in your data mean? So
like in order for me to actually eval
this correctly, what I need to be able
to do is I have run this like two weeks
ago last time I last time I was building
this prompt. Then a new engineer comes
on and let's assume the models have
stayed constant the whole time. Nothing
has changed about the model in some way
and a new engineer has come and started
updating this prompt in some way. What
they really want to know is the last
time I ran this I got this output. The
next time I ran this I got this output.
And so that's like on your PR you could
get a like output from some eval system
that basically says like cool here's a
here's a link to a page about how all
the outputs have changed between the
first one and the second one and someone
can literally go skim those and eyeball
those and say like oh that that's a huge
block of red let's go see if I broke
some edge case that we know we want to
make sure still works exactly and you
can even build a uh you can even build
like a rule set around that is like hey
my diff for my eval should be small so
you measure the lines of diff in your
eval. So like even even though it's a
text thing, you can build a diffing a
diffing score of how big of a diff you
have. And the and the fact of the matter
is because these are proistic systems,
you really have to go look at
this. Uh what is that question uh that
someone had? I see I can I can imagine
seeing a huge wave of error messages
being mentioned by the LLM being a good
flag for people having issues. I don't
understand that question John if you
could articulate that'd be helpful and
exact I think Jonathan nailed it. very
similar to screenshot UIs like there's
like front end I whenever you work on
front end code for the first time you're
like why does no one write unit test and
you write unit test and you quickly
realize if I write unit test it slows
down my shipping by like a bajillion
orders of magnitude
um and eval systems are really similar
because the way you would write a unit
test is not useful for most of it in
this case I don't need to say I have no
desire to say exactly what the key
insight is there's so many different
ways to say these same
topics. It's totally
useless. But I do want to say one of the
key insights should include the words
React and
Next.js. So like I can go build a a
stronger eval over time. And what I
really need to make sure is no matter
what happens, no matter what the prompt
is, it always answers React and Next.js
in all scenarios. And I have a good
system. My primary intents can be
hardcoded.
um for now. Yes. Uh so is everyone
making their own internal full stack
eval
applications? I wouldn't really say
they're full stack eval applications. I
would just view it as
like when you write like code. Uh when
you write code like this, like you don't
expect anyone else to write your React
components for you. Your React
components are very special to your own
websites. Your functions are very
special to your own system. You might
use really core infrastructure, but you
typically will
use systems and things you don't care
about. You will offload like some we
don't all care about that chat widget
that pops up on our website and we're
okay offloading that to someone else
because we as a social paradigm have
built that sort of paradigm out there.
So even some eval like hey maybe someone
has built a really good sentiment
analysis email eval for like e-commerce
chat
bots. That's okay. We can leverage that
just like we could build we could use
that little chat UI
widget, but we probably won't build our
entire website off of widgets that we
don't
own. And that's that's really what we
recommend, which is learn how to write
the
eval. And then as you write the evals,
it becomes really really easy to kind of
build small little test harnesses like
this one. And then you just run that on
a bunch of data sets and you dump out
files and you build small visualizers to
go do this. And I would never like
Dexter was saying like this is a game
that has changed now. Before you would
have to compromise on worse dashboards,
worse system, but now if you're an
engineer working on a part of a
pipeline, just build it. And it's like
you can building an Nex.js object that
renders a type that is well defined
because you have a type here that you
can just render. You want to render a
lesson plan object, go do that. You want
to build like uh you want to build you
want to render this right? We got you
can we got seven minutes. You want to
show us how you vibe code a eval
visualizer? Yeah. Like let's make let's
make 10 test cases on third grade math
topics and like let's vibe eval. Let's
do it. Let me go run this really fast in
that case. Yeah, we got seven minutes
but I think um as usual we'll probably
go over um let me just ping and see if
we have any other questions. Um yes. So
is everyone making their own internal
full stack eval applications? Sounds
like maybe some people you probably
should maybe um and Andy had a good
question is like is it the same model
call that is generating the eval or a
second agent? Um and I get this question
a lot as well. While you're doing that,
I'll just kind of like think through
this out loud and then I want to get
your answer, which is basically that
idea of
um
like if you ask one model to do a thing
and then you ask another model to
evaluate the thing, maybe you get some
value from cross-pollination. I see this
a lot in like consensus pipelines as
well, where you say like, okay, here's
the question. let me fork it off to four
of the best models and then let me have
a fifth model basically review all the
answers of those four models and then
decide which one is better. Right? I
think DSPI calls this like a consensus
or a judge plan or something like this.
Um,
and the question I always have is like,
well, if the model couldn't get it right
the first time, is the same model going
to be able to get it right the second
time? And or like, if the second model
is smarter than the first model, why
don't you just ask the second model like
in the first place? And I think um there
is a little bit to be said for I think
there's a couple papers on like if you
ask llama 70B the same question 50 times
you get almost as good performance as
llama 405b or something like you there
is value into doing these things over
and over again and then like
synthesizing the results.
Um let's see.
I think u I think that like should use
the same model for everything. Like no
just like your agent should not be the
same model everywhere. Like instead of
viewing this whole thing as like a
separate people I think it's the same
mistake that people do when they build
like entire AI pipelines. They're like
my agent is one thing but your agent is
decomposed of many many boxes. in my
chat agent. The thing that builds the
intent analysis could be a really really
simple GPT40 mini model. Maybe even a
llama 8B. Who knows? But the thing that
generates a SQL query, maybe that can be
a 70B model. And the thing that does a
cipher query against my entire like data
warehouse, we're going to use 03. The
fact that I'm using different models for
them is more of a necessity for how
ambiguous and hard the problem is.
And now what you can do over here
instead is you can just do the same
thing here. Our eval system could use a
different model here. Like in this case
I'm using the same one. I don't think it
really matters, but I will switch to
open eye really fast. Um actually I
don't care. Let's use Sonic. It doesn't
really matter. Um and we'll go run this.
And now I I built this in. So the first
thing I'm going to go do and this is
what gets ends up being really hard
about eval systems is a lot of times
people assume that eval systems are easy
but they end up being really hard
because I do not want like if one of
these asserts fails I get no information
about the other asserts and that's
actually where things end up being
really hard to go read and write and
also if I forget to save the data before
I actually run this that's another thing
that ends up being hard so selfishly I
was actually hoping to show this off
later in about like three weeks because
we had a new thing that was going to
make this way way way better. But I'll
go write the code. Let's see it.
Um uh test
one. So now we have two tests that we're
going to run. And then we'll just run
like I think like pi
test import.
You probably have to UV add it.
Um
yep. Nice. It's probably this. I have no
idea.
UV add pi
test and then one second. I got to put
my API key. Am I still sharing the
window? I'm not. Right.
Uh we don't see the terminal. We just
see the cursor. And yeah, John, that's a
great comment. Evals are a great use
case for switching out a models on which
model delivers the best value for cost.
Exactly. Yeah. And that comes back to a
thing we come to all the time, which is
like make it work. I mean in design and
like product engineer we call it like
make it run, make it right, make it fast
and like in LM world it's like fast and
cheap I guess. Um, but it's it's like,
yeah, get the thing working and then if
you have a good eval set, you can say,
"Cool, we're going to try to rebuild
this pipeline with 40 mini and just make
the prompt really good instead of using
03." And you'll know exactly how much
better 03 was than 40 mini. And you'll
know exactly how you're doing at
changing your prompts to make, you know,
040 mini almost as good as
03. Why is this failing? Well, we'll
find out. I forgot to run dash s. Let me
run that again.
Also, I think you're having like async
io thing. I don't know. Let's see. Uh,
I'm not I'm not running async. I
probably should. Okay. Uh, and I'm
running. So, the first thing I'm doing,
I'm really just going to run this
because I just wrote some test cases.
I'm going to go run it. Test index zero,
test index one, and then it's going to,
and you can actually see what it did.
pulled out the lesson plan
and then it's going to take the lesson
plan and pull this out and said pacing
was medium biases physical activity like
hopscotch might be challenging. That's
true. Like maybe physical activities are
actually bad. Group dance activities
might and then competition is bad. Um
and then now there's another one that
says a pizza uh pizza activity. And what
does this do? And this failed because I
forgot to make a
directory. Uh new folder evals.
Okay. And then what I'll do is
date
equals. And you can see what the most
annoying part about this is, which is
why I wanted to show the cleaner code,
but that's
okay. Um, there we go. Okay, that looks
pretty good.
Well, no. Just like what I mean is like
you can see how there's so much work
that I have to do just to get the data
out of the system. Like when I'm
building an LM pipeline, this is
actually one of the most annoying parts.
So like what what I'm really excited
about is being able to run BML CLI tests
and automatically be able to have the
diffing and everything done for you
automatically and just have JSON stuff
save. Oh, like is it going to dump out
all the input output pairs to like some
temporary storage space or something?
Yeah, exactly. like BAML CLI test and
like be able to even even better just do
something like this
D-pro dash like compare equals prod till
the two and you can just get the last
two entries in prod and compare against
them. Oh, sick. That's like the git
syntax or whatever. Yeah, just use
syntax to kind of invent that for us.
Um, and I have to make a new directory.
Just my two cents. I use BL CLI test a
lot and it's really really good. Gives
me feedback very rapidly, but then you
can't do the diff right now. So I end up
writing manual Python code to do the
diffs. Yep. That's kind of why. And you
can kind of see what I'm doing with the
diff here. Uh and really what I do with
the diff is once I have this generated,
this will generate in a couple
seconds. Um and it'll write everything
down. Um and the other benefit once you
do that is you can get caching and
everything for free. So you can like
modify your eval prompt without having
to modify this prompt. Uh which is kind
of nice. But like we can just see what's
happening and like this looks pretty
good. So now what I would
do is now this is good and this actually
failed. That's fine. I don't really care
because I saved all the data. Um and now
what I would do
is for every run I just build a UI that
actually does this for me. So let me
make an MPM folder.
tsj cdts. If we have time, I have a I
have a funky example cooking over here
as well that we can look at. Okay, but
this is structurally super super
interesting and helpful. Wait, why did
this Oh, I'm dumb. This is another thing
that happens when you do
this. Um, you realize that you save data
into the wrong folder. I need one date
folder for my entire run, not multiple.
Oh yeah, you got to make it one
time. Okay.
Okay, cool. And this is what I end up
doing now. So I'll show you guys my
exact
workflow. I go here. I say I will
run some tests each time. Um and all my
tests will be in that folder
structure for each
run.
Run_ate
slash at
data test
idx.json. Oh I hate this. Stop.
Stop.
Okay. Sorry, maybe I'll cut that
out. Um, and then and then you want to
actually paste in the data format,
right? Here's an example of actually
what I really like to do more than that
is actually
um what I'll often do and this this I
find works even better. Yeah. Um of the
type I'm saving in the JSON. Look, it
wouldn't be an episode of AI that works
if I Bob didn't sneak in a uh BAML is
more token efficient than JSON quip. I
haven't said that yet.
You implied it.
Well, I guess this is putting in the
types rather than the data themselves,
which is probably much more interesting
for building UIs. Exactly. Exactly.
Because like that the model, if I give
it this shape, it won't actually know.
But if I give it lesson plan
string and then what's the next one
evaluation and the thing is like I just
paste the stuff in there and it kind of
just it'll figure something out. It
doesn't really matter. Is lesson plan a
string? I thought it was the Yes, the
lesson plan type. This is why it's great
to have someone else there. Um I want to
render a
diff of Oh shoot. I forgot to say one
more thing. Dang it.
I want to and while this runs I'll rerun
this. I want to render a diff
of diff evaluations per topic
over
multiple multiple runs to
show the diff between lesson plans.
then
also show the
um plans
um and their
evaluations. Cool. I'll let this run.
While I do this, I'm going to fix my my
my sin that I wrote over here, which is
I forgot to dump out the topic.
And this is what I mean by it's very
easy when you go write these systems
out to actually like accidentally do
something that you didn't mean to and
like just forget to go do something. And
like imagine you spent
like two $5,000 running this and you
just forgot to record the topic. You're
basically doomed. You just have there
there's no shortcut. And this is why I
this is so hard to do because it's not
like even me going into this. I know I
need to save the topic and I forgot
until the very end.
So like
uh where did it
go?
Yes. I will run this
again. Um and now it'll go do something
for me and it'll probably be somewhat
reasonable
um when it does this. And now the good
part by the way is like if you want you
can just code gen these types in
TypeScript pretty easily for BAML 2. So
let's just go do that. Why not? Um I
will do that as soon as it's done.
Uh, nice. Now we have this.
Okay. Um, and then this will go do some
stuff for me. The problem is you end up
waiting. But this is way better than
trying to figure out some other system
that isn't going to be perfect. Uh,
because I can get this to be very
correct. Can use eval history to
backfill topic? You can, but then you're
basically just data cleaning and data
cleaning sucks. It's honestly just
faster to rerun it.
But now you can actually see what it
did. It's kind of cool. It actually
built the system out for me. lets me
compare and just lets me pull that out.
Um, and it'll actually show me the diff.
And you can see how fast I did
this, right? It's not that hard as at
all. Um, I just use cursor. It doesn't
really matter. The reason I use v0ero is
because I don't have to spin up a whole
node project. Then I can just see if
it's if it's actually what I want up
front. And once it is, then I then I
download it. Then I move over onto
cursor. Um, if that makes sense,
pashant.
So, but like you can see how fast this
is. It's like great. And I can actually
see the difference. It's like cool. And
it's actually showing me what I
have. And like now I have an email
suite. This is sick. And I'm like, "Oh,
now give me a clickth through button up
here." So I can just click and just
compare, compare, compare, and I'm done.
And then also load this from disk. And
now I built an eval system in under five
minutes. I can iterate on my lesson plan
really, really
fast. This is how I think people should
build
eval. And if you're not doing this,
you're hurting yourself and your company
and your likelihood of success of
building a successful pipeline. So like
the whole goal is go from like
So yeah, I would say like let's like can
we put together a checklist in like the
read me here or something of just like
what's the steps, what should I do first
and like what are the what what are all
my boxes to check to know that I'm kind
of like on the right path to make this
happen. Yeah, that's a great that's a
great thing. So I think step number one
that everyone should be doing vibe
evals. That's it. Just vi. What does
that what So what does that mean to you?
To me what that means is you're going in
the playground and just hitting play
constantly and you're actually looking
at the data. That's part one. Okay. Step
number two. As soon as you've got your
five eval down like that means you're
actually reading your prompt, you're
writing test cases and you're actually
hitting play. And just care think about
what test cases actually make sense. And
even the act of thinking about test
cases is going to help you be better at
your system because you're going to
think about where people can fail. I
remember when the minute I started
talking about eval people like oh uh
there I forgot the messages on here but
in the thread people were directly
saying that there's so many different
ways to measure the lesson plan and
they're like you could think about a few
I forgot the I I don't section people
instantly had ways to judge the plan. do
that for your own prompts. Like just
write a few.
Two, capture the intermediate steps of
your entire pipeline and try and eval
the steps that are most easy to eval.
Don't try and pipeline. Yeah, this comes
back to like the the testing pyramid,
right? Of like you should have small
super granular tests and then you should
also have uh what is it? Testing pyramid
Oh
man, for formal term terminology for
all. Exactly. Yeah. Exactly. Exactly.
This is the thing of like you should
have little incremental tests at the
smallest possible granularity because
these are faster, they're more isolated
and you can iterate quicker and then you
should have end to end I mean in in the
AI case it's not UI tests, it's like end
to end full pipeline tests. Yeah. Um but
this idea like a lot of your tests
should be these smaller more granular
units. Yeah. Because if you know that
the intent capturing is correct, we can
worry about the next steps, not the
first steps. Um, if you know your
messages have the right tone because you
look at them and you vibe eval them, you
can worry about the intent analysis
being correct. Exactly. Engineering is
engineering. Um, there's no shortcut
here. So that's those are like two big
ones. Things that I recommend focusing
energy on as a team is I always
recommend people build structured
outputs uh whenever possible and like
break your problems down. Like Daxter
says this all the time and is one of
those things like think of all LM things
as tools or really just classes that
you're
returning like once you're able to do
that it becomes really really easy to
write evals for certain parts of your
pipeline. Um and then really it's more
about don't use numbers for confidence
scores. Uh and the reason you don't use
numbers because like when I got an
English paper I remember this all the
time. I don't understand why I got a 92
instead of a 97 half the time. It felt
like discretion. Well, okay, that's I
realize this was the uh Are we bragging
about our English paper scores now? Let
me be more honest. An 82 instead of a
97. Um, listen, you don't have to lie.
We love you for who you are. Um, yes.
Uh, that's right. But in reality, I
never understood what those numbers
meant because they felt very
arbitrary. And most people when they
give a numerical system don't have a
system. They have like a completely
arbitrary system. So it's like you
notice that when I actually wrote the
eval system when I was writing it is I
just asked it and like the model came up
with a good idea for what an eval system
is for that but categorical
categorical systems are generally way
better than numerical systems because no
one knows the difference between score
seven and eight. So don't don't put a
category in there that has no meaning.
This is do you put like emu enums in
that as well of like outputting like a
string that represents like a category?
Yeah. when you had like slow versus
medium versus fast, right? Exactly.
Exactly. And like Jonathan said it
right. It's like it's same with stars on
Yelp. Like I don't go to a restaurant
that has less than 4.8 because that
means they suck. Uh like if they don't
have a 4.8, they're just really bad. Um
and it's more about thinking about
categories better. And you can add
descriptions to categories to say
exactly what they mean and just break
your problem down to a classification
problem. you on the probe on the probe
question real quick that just came up. I
I think the idea here would be like in
your we'll share this in the whiteboard,
but basically like you have your full
pipeline where you pull out an intent
and then you list the products for that
intent and then you build your answer
and you return the answer and you also
return things about the intermediate
step so that in your test you get the
output and the probe. And we're actually
not going to make assertions about the
answer because it's like a chatbot
generated big string. Maybe you can. But
the idea is like let's make assertions
about so that when this test fails for
some reason, maybe we are also
evaluating the answer. We immediately
have assertions about each intermediate
step as well that we can see like oh the
intent was wrong and so everything was
screwed up. And the alternative here is
this concept is I think the concept that
people are most familiar with that looks
like this is mocking.
So instead of uh instead of actually
doing it's like you could technically
mock what get in intense does and then
you kind of have um you can kind of eval
just the next part of your system if
that makes sense, right? You test your
get intense function and then you can
mock it in your pipeline and you say hey
as long as we get the intents right and
we get the products right then the we
are just now testing the final chat
output. So that's an alternative to
probes right? Can you they're kind of
similar. Can you go back to your system
the diagram that you had really fast
just to articulate this better? So like
here you can imagine that I wrote it. So
probes are one way to do it. It's the
easiest way for most people to do it for
people that are more uh that are more
comfortable with mocking. What I would
recommend is in and in chatbot you could
just mock the get products function and
the chat response function to return a
fixed thing. Well, you don't have to
pass it in. You can just use a mocking
library. Sure. And then you can just
mock what get products and chat response
does like like yeah there's exactly you
get the point. And now what you can say
is now you can basically assert what
intent should be in your mocked
functions. So there's multiple ways to
go write this code out. Yeah.
Exactly.
Exactly. Oh, I can't believe you
actually know this off top of your head.
This is why you're a much better
engineer than me. I don't know about
that. Um I do not know this stuff. I
just uh Yeah. So, and then you can
Exactly. And so then you don't really
care about this probe stuff anymore and
you're just going to like break down the
problem and solve it at each level of
the pyramid basically. Exactly. So now
if you have ever seen this talk, we'll
put in the show notes. Uh I think it's
JD
Reignsburgger degraded test scam. Uh,
this is an incredible talk. Um, yeah,
integrated tests are a scam. It's an
hour and five minutes on why only
testing things end to end is going to
destroy your team and your product and
your company and the value of like
following this pyramid and focusing on
small pieces and the contracts between
parts of the system. Yeah. And then can
you go back and then uh Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Sorry, not to here to the
dashboard uh to the notes that you're
writing. Yep.
Um and really this is a checklist and
and I think the most important part is
uh yeah what else is missing from this?
Oh sorry one last thing use prod data to
build up your build up your golden data
set continuously over time do not stop
uh specifically you should write only
integration only using integration tests
is a scam.
Sorry. Yeah integration tests are
fantastic and you should have
integration tests but if you only have
integration tests you are being scammed.
Yeah. Well, it's like if you're if
you're using an integration test to
catch a thing that broke between these
two small components of the system, it's
quickly going to explode into 700
integration tests that are very slow to
run and very slow to run one of them,
let alone run all of them. And when one
of them breaks, it's going to be very
unclear which part of the pipeline
broke. Exactly. Um, and I and I'm going
to pause here because I think uh
hopefully what I can do is I can send
over like some actual like tooling
scripts that we have that have been
useful, but we'll share some of them
pretty soon. But really, you want things
that can
pull pull d. What you really need is you
need something that can pull data from
prod. You need to build tooling to
visualize the differences between
different
outputs. And you just need to make that
really easy so that every engineer wants
to go do that all the time. And I think
the best analogy I have at this is like
back at the hedge fund that I was
working at, they have they had like
around I think um their unit test used
to take like 30 something hours to go
run. So obviously none of the engineers
ever ran the unit test or they'd run
like the one file that they know. But we
all know that changing one um one file
running one file unit test is often not
good enough.
So like what we found was we built a
system that could say given a git diff
we wanted to predict exactly all the
unit tests that would need to be run and
we actually built that system and we
found that on average for 90% of commits
people had about five minutes of test to
run and that changed how people ran
worked because they always ran all the
tests like because they just and what we
did was we made a single command. It was
called delta test. you would just run
delta test and look at your diff and be
like, "Ah, this is what you need to
run." It would just run it for you. And
that was actually even easier for people
to run than actually determining
um than actually like even thinking
about the file that they're run because
even one less work work
item. And I think people need something
like that for AI systems. Like if
someone is working on a prompt, they
don't have to think about running a unit
test for that prompt. They want to run
something like delta test and basically
say run the entire pipeline that depends
on that test and never think about it
again. And I think that is going to be
the answer. Steve, you had a question.
So now that you've teased everyone with
this magic system, how was that? How
were the what training was used to then
predict you know what tests to run? Like
what did that look like at a high level?
I wrote an
algorithm. There was really an algorithm
that I wrote. So were you like parsing
the parsing the a of the entire codebase
and then doing a like analyzing the
graph basically? Yes. But the only
problem is in Python you can modify
global variables and changes the a quite
in nasty ways and then you have C Python
code that you have to deal with and then
network dependencies and data
dependencies. So I wrote an algorithm to
deal with that. Um it was fun. It was
very fun. um a lot of state um testing.
So I think we'll probably end up
building something like that for um LMS
because I think people want something
like that as well. We got a good
question from Adisha here. Um struggling
a bit to understand the value of the
different UI. Okay, let me let me tell
you why why you want the dipping UI. Can
we like whiteboard out like the workflow
steps or something like that? Yeah. What
screen am I sharing? This is
cursor.
Cursor. Do you see cursor? What do you
see now?
Uh I saw trees for a sec and now I see
cursor. Oh yeah, now I see it. Okay. Why
is this better? Well, Adisha, the most
important part here that you have to uh
kind of uh get around is that when you
go do
this, this is just easier to go read
than looking at JSON dumps. And when
you're looking at hundreds of them, you
need to go do this. And it's not
actually it's not embarrassing at all.
It's actually it's really really
intuitive. It's it makes sense like hey
we're programmers we're engineers we run
all this stuff programmatically why are
we suddenly building UIs for this and I
think the best analogy is data science
we all have recognized Jupyter notebook
is incredibly powerful for data
scientists and for machine learning
people and the reason Jupyter notebook
is really powerful because it combines
visuals with
code and that's what you need to do when
you're in this world you need to look at
visuals plus code to get really fast
feedback and really this isn't even good
enough it's like I want to I want an
arrow I can click to
quickly skim test uh
indexes. Like I really want an arrow
that I can click that'll just like do it
for me so I can just like make it really
really
fast. Um and I think once you get in the
habit of thinking of it this way, like I
used to get so annoyed every time I had
to spin up a Jupyter notebook because I
was like I have to install IPI kernel
and I have to like remember what it is.
But once you get in the habit of it,
it's like there's no better way to build
plots and analyze data because I'm
manipulating things all the time. Um,
and I think normally I would say stick
to Python if that's what you're most
comfortable in. But the problem is you
we're no longer looking at graphs and
analytics. We're looking at things that
are a lot less graphical.
No, they don't just like plug into
standard components like an XYaxis or a
pandas table. Exactly. And that's not
what we're doing. So it's like, okay,
now I have to just like and now I just
want to like rotate here and just like
go do this. And it's like I don't know
why it's taking forever to load. It's so
slow. I'm like, okay. And I'm I'm
literally just going to tell like
instead of
loading load everything at once, then
show it so it doesn't
lag when I uh press
next. And like it'll it'll just figure
things out. And I don't actually spend a
lot of time while I'm doing this because
what I often do is like I'm iterating on
this thing while it's running and then
while I'm on there I'm actually like
just running stuff in the playground
looking at things manually to build a
better you're changing your prompt and
then you're looking at how the diff
change and then you're changing your
prompt you're changing the order of
functions. I mean, this is all about
again that quick like iteration loop at
the end of the day. Like, yes, this is
useful as an artifact to like before PR
goes in like eyeball and make sure it's
not going to break anything too
impactful. But it's also it's like cool,
I'm trying to make this thing more
accurate or I'm going to try to like I'm
trying I'm trying to get it. It's 99%
but it always up this weird edge
case. Can I change the prompt or change
the pipeline or change the format to get
this weird edge case? And this becomes
the thing that you can do to be like,
cool, I solved my problem. Oh, but I
broke seven other things. And it's very
visually like I clicked three times and
I can see that it's broken. So, we have
to go back to the drawing board.
Exactly. And it's just going to be
faster to iterate. It's it's it's really
annoying. I know for a lot of people
this feels annoying, but um like I
honestly I have nothing to say. And
you're going to see how like nice this
is. I can just like look at this like
cool and I can just like manually see
like what's happening between the two
and I can be like cool this is the
difference.
Yeah. And you can show this to a
non-technical person and you can say
like, "Hey, here's how we're improving
this week versus last week." Exactly.
Um, and this is really it just makes
life way
faster. And and by the way, don't do
this the minute you start writing your
prompts. Do not do this. The answer
is look at it 5 valid. Honestly, I ship
things with five evals and that's okay.
I've seen many people do that because
what we want to do is 5 eval. that's
good enough. Ship it to prod, collect
prod data, use prod data to build golden
data sets, and then build diffing and
all this other tooling. After that, we
had a we had a really mediocre prompt
live in our production systems for about
12 weeks. And then one day, a customer
wrote in was like, "Hey, it did this one
thing weird." And we went and we found
the exact data from the weird thing it
did. We added that to our test case
suite and said, "We need to handle this
as well." And we grabbed a couple other
weird test cases while we were in there.
like some of this stuff doesn't look
right. And the issue was we had this
thing where like a smaller model like a
40 mini was kind of just like
regurgitating data from its training
set. I don't know if you all have ever
seen that thing. It was like okay cool
like let's add a couple tests for these
weird things and let's change the
prompt. And we actually ended up
changing the model which broke a bunch
of our existing tests. So we had to
change the because 40 is a lot more it
it's a lot smarter but it's also a lot
smarter. And so some of the things that
we were relying on GPT4 many to do
cleanly because it's too dumb to
actually think about the problem. We had
to go like change the prompt to be like
don't try to be smart about this. Don't
try to answer the question. Just just
pull the text
out. Um but anyway that that's like a
real workflow that we had in production
where it's like we shipped a prompt that
was like pretty good. I vibed it on a
couple things and then I waited for it
to break and then we iterated as we go.
I mean, putting things that you know are
going to break is bad, but also like
spending six months on evals before you
ship a product to somebody and like find
out if they even want it is really
dangerous. Yes, it's way worse. And
think of it like that fake buy now
button that we used to have on websites,
but they literally just do that to see
if you clicked on it and if you clicked
on it, they'd be like, "Shit, we should
sell that thing." And then they'd go
sell it. Yeah. And now you're called it
the fake door test. You'd be like, "If
people try to open the door, then you
know they want to go in there and then
you go, you know, build out whatever's
supposed to be behind it." Yeah. If
people are complaining about your
system, then you you have real data that
you can work with to make it better. All
right, let's do one or two more
questions and then we should probably
wrap up. Yes, we're 30 minute 25 minutes
over. Two last questions and we will
call it quits for today. Um, and if
there no more questions, we can call it
quits and go back to
work. What's a good mental model to when
to split a prompt into intermediate
steps? Um, I don't think there's
generally a great model because it
really depends on the capacity of the
model that you're using. If you're using
an AB model, it's probably earlier
rather than later. If you're using a if
you're using a if you're using a
stronger model, but your your steps are
very very intertwined, it might be
earlier rather than later because you
might want have value in discreetly
defining those steps. It's really about
how well you can define the problem. And
honestly, just like press play and keep
on testing it until you get to a good
point. Like you you have to build that
intuition yourself based on your domain.
Yep. All right. One more question. Would
it make sense to self- introspect on
outputs during runtime and correct them
if the LMS take no time to output and
eval?
Yeah. Uh that's basically what we did
the deterministic runtime evals that we
did of adding stuff table-wise and
row-wise. Does it make sense to also do
kind of introspective LLM based evals at
runtime if they're if they're fast?
I mean I mean whether you're using an
LLM or like math to do that calculation
doesn't really matter. It's up to you
and you can definitely definitely do
that. And we have people the the
financial thing I've shown is I've seen
multiple people take variations of that
approach to build like document uh
validation for all sorts of things and
like we have people running pipelines
with 99% plus accuracy on like a 100page
plus PDFs on data extraction. it works
because what ends up happening is when
things go wrong, they literally ask an
LLM to go fix the thing that went wrong.
And because of how LM's work, because
they're now focusing on just one part of
it, they're able to go get the right
answer more often than not
afterwards. So, if you get feedback from
an LLM, like a really tiny one, maybe a
1D model or something that you're
running on an edge device, you can use
that to build corrective behavior as
long as as long as the thing that you're
measuring on is actually good. Um, and I
was showing this for example, like right
over here, like you can imagine for this
visa form, I could build the same
system. I'll find everyone that was
flagged as first trip to Cambodia true
in my data set, and if they're flagged
as true, first trip to Cambodia, I'll
make sure a human looks at it. If it's
false, what I'll do is I'll literally
look up their passport number or
whatever I have in here, I'll look up
their passport number in my database and
see how much of the information
validates. If everything matches and
it's all the same, but the address is
different, I'll kick it off to human and
have them only compare the address and
say like, is this the right is this a
good up-to-date address? Should we
update this? Or maybe even email the
person be like, are you are you sure you
want to validate your address at this at
this way? And I've kind of built this
automated system. That's an incredible
note to close on. Um to summarize all of
this is building evals is not that hard
and it's not that much code. Um, I think
there's a lot of like eval systems off
the shelf that you can buy that force
you into a very structured way of
thinking about this problem, but at the
end of the day, none of them will let
you build the pipeline that Vivov just
described. And as you scale, it might
make sense to grab a solution off the
shelf. But at the start, you should
understand what you're testing, how
you're testing it, and like keep the
flexibility to build this however you
want, so that you can have a really
flexible pipeline architecture, and you
can evolve your testing systems with it.
Dexter nailed it. I I will add the
links, the vzero, and we'll push the
code up so you can just see what that
ends up looking like as a whole. Real
quick announcement, thank you, Andrew.
Uh we are doing a workshop. If you're in
San Francisco, um we'll post the link.
Um but um we are going to do a all day
workshop mini conference in SF. Um so if
you're in town uh come hang out. It's
going to be a good time. We just did it
in New York last weekend. People loved
it. So should be great. Um and then um
we'll see you guys next week.
All right, folks.
Bye everyone. See you. Bye.